hello believes nation today we're going
to talk about the seven reasons why you
haven't achieved your ultimate goal so
[Music]
get a lot of entrepreneurs running into
me asked me comment on YouTube sending
me snaps and Instagram questions the
base was saying I have these goals I
know what I want to do I have this
vision it's so clear in my head but I'm
not following through I'm not doing the
work I haven't been able to achieve my
goal yet and I thought I would have
already done it by now what's the
problem so I'm going to share with you
the seven reasons why you haven't
achieved your goal and hopefully if some
of them resonate with you you can fix it
so that you can achieve your goals this
year reason number one is you're afraid
of failure this is one of the biggest
reasons why people don't get started
it's easy to think of an idea it's easy
to put yourself there you're on that
Island because you've sold this company
you've had too much success and you just
see the impact that you're having and
you're winning awards or whatever it is
and it's fun to kind of live in that
fantasy Lane for a while but then the
other side comes in when you're afraid
that what if it doesn't work what if I
lose my money what if you know things
wonder what if I lose my house what if
what if what if for different was my
relationship falls apart all of these
negativities that come in and so
understanding that that is a story that
you're you're holding yourself back on
because most people are afraid of
failure but they'll mask it with some
practical reason why they can't do it
that's the biggest reason that's the
biggest thing that hold people really
back really you're just afraid to go out
and do it you're afraid of failing
but you convince yourself that it's for
a practical reason that you're not going
to get started you tell yourself that
you don't have the education you don't
have the money or now it's not the right
time you're just too busy right now or
bla bla bla bla bla some kind of reason
right but really at the core of it's
just you're afraid of people and so
recognizing that all the excuses that
you have in front of you or just BS
excuses that other people have already
had way more success than you with way
fewer resources and education and in
talent than you have within yourself you
have nobody to blame but yourself and
recognizing that it's just fear that's
holding you back allows you to address
the problem
allows you to mitigate the fear to
minimize it to go after your goal and do
something nothing to see on a big scale
yet but taking small steps though every
step along the way you're reducing more
fear we do some more for fear reducing
more fear understand the real reason
that's causing you to not go forward on
your goal and break through those BS
excuses that you're telling yourself
[Music]
number two is you're afraid of being
judged this one is a super scary one too
it's not just a fear failing it's a fear
feeling in front of other people what
will people think if you don't do well
what will people think by your idea if
it's not perfect what would people think
if you make a youtube video and you post
it and it's not perfect it's not great
it's not the best you can do
what will your parents think or your
husband or wife think or your kids think
or your high school classmates think
your university friends think if your
thing doesn't work out and what it
forces people to do is then play small
because you're so worried about what
other people will think that when you
want to start coming up here you smash
yourself back down is a Japanese phrase
I'm going to I'm going to butcher it but
there's a thing basically where you if
you're a nail sticking out you get hit
back down
right so it's conformity if you want to
live a life of conformity then you're
always going to be exactly like
everybody else around you nobody's going
to ever create anything unique because
you're all trying to be vanilla because
you're afraid of being judged with
somebody else and so again recognizing
that that's your fear and developing the
muscle to break through it whenever for
me whatever I try to do when I'm when
I'm worried that I'm being judged when
I'm worried about somebody else's
opinion of me
then I force myself to go through with
it not in a way that's offending them
it's not to show it in their face say
hey look what I did but me on my path so
I've told the server when I was walking
to Toronto doing salsa and I had music
on right and I'm bouncing them grooving
and I'm driving down the street and then
I got to the busy intersection I started
I started doing it much smaller movement
I just subconsciously we do this
subconsciously we fear judgment
subconsciously
and when I recognize that then I force
myself to dance big on the street again
even as a nooner right now there's
people walking by me to this side watch
like what's this guy doing dancing in
the studio doesn't matter right like
feeling that discomfort and working your
way through it builds the muscle so that
you could do it again and again and
again each time in more powerful ways so
anytime you feel that you were holding
yourself back from doing something that
you really want to do because you're
worried about being judged by somebody
else and that's a signal in my mind at
least that you need to go and do it you
have to force yourself to feel the
discomfort and break through it so that
you're building the muscle for the next
time it doesn't happen and the next time
you're stronger and the next time you're
able to break through and do something
even bigger fear of somebody else's
judgment of you should not be the reason
why you don't chase your dream number
three is the fear of success this is a
crazy sounding one why would I fear
success a lot of people do for the
negative ones it's easy to understand
right you're free to failure you're a
creative of the judgment that's easy to
understand why would I be afraid of
success for a lot of people that means
that they're going to leave their
situation they may leave their family
they mean leave their friends behind
they're going to leave their community
pond as they move off with some other
place and that's scary and a lot of
people will then self-sabotage they'll
reach a certain level of success and
they'll sabotage themselves to fall back
down because they don't want to leave
the people behind them and again it's an
idea of playing small because all these
people around you are not chasing their
dreams are not doing the thing that they
want to do are not recognizing their
genius level Michael Jordan level talent
at whatever they're doing they don't
want to go up and do it and so makes you
feel like you don't want to go up and do
it as well and as soon as you start
rising up a lot of times people will
then sabotage themselves to fall back
down because it's more comfortable to be
in their current environment that's why
the environment is so important we're
touching out a little bit later so if
you've ever reached the point where
you've had some success and then you
find yourself getting in your own way
ask yourself if you're afraid of success
if you're afraid of more success you're
afraid of leaving your group behind
because that limiting belief until
they're back
[Music]
the number four reason why you haven't
achieved your ultimate goal yet is you
just don't care enough a lot of people
set their own goals a lot of people when
you say what is your ultimate goal they
come up with something that actually
doesn't motivate them they want to buy a
Ferrari that's their ultimate goal
things like you don't actually care that
much about buying that for are the thing
that you say you care so much about you
don't actually care that much about it
how does a lot of people it's one of the
main reasons why entrepreneurs fail why
eighty to ninety percent of companies
shut down depending on whatever that you
follow because they just don't care
enough about their business they got
into it for the wrong reason you have to
love your craft if you look at all the
videos that we've done all the different
payments on trainers we've profiled it's
one of the most consistent messages you
have to love what you do so if you're
doing something for the wrong reason
you're never going to get to that finish
line one good way to figure it out is if
you knew you would never make money at
this would you still do it I love
helping entrepreneurs it's in me to my
fabric I love it I would do it even if
it wasn't make money in fact most of
time I'm not making money when I'm
helping entrepreneurs I just I love it
it feels me out that fooled me and when
I first started along this path I had
three people show up to my first free
event and I thought I'm never going to
make money doing this but I just loved
it so much I had to find a way you never
had to do other things this I would
continue doing because I love it so much
you have to love your work that much you
have to love the person you're with that
much you have to love your life that
much you have to love that goal that you
have that much that you would do it even
if it didn't make any sense even if it
never made you any money that you would
still do it if you have that level of
care then you'll get there but most
people don't does they pick the wrong
goal really number five is you are not
consistent this happens to so many
entrepreneurs we're not consistent you
may have one day where you're on fire
and energetic and closing deals and
working hard and grinding in hustling
and then the next day you're not working
as hard anymore
and this is roller coaster ride up up
and working hard and then nothing
nothing working hard and then nothing
and oftentimes it may be because you
know you read a book you listen to a
podcast you watch the video and I got
you inspired but you're not consistent
consistency is going to be the key
if you look at the people who are the
greatest in the world at what they do
they practice whether you believe in a
10,000 hour rule or not they practiced
they put their hours in they worked hard
you know I've made almost 4,000 videos
on this channel a lot of videos
you better get packed decently good
after you've done something whatever it
is 4,000 times and so you have to be
consistent you have to find a way to
make sure that every single day even if
you have a job right now you've other
responsibilities right now it's fine I
get it it's not that you have to go
full-time you have to burn the boats and
forget everything else happen in your
life but it also doesn't mean that you
do work only on Mondays and the rest of
the week you've got nothing else you're
busy with the rest of your life you're
not going to get anywhere if you're
practicing something once a week you're
not going to get anywhere has to be
daily you have to find the time to spend
time daily at least 30 to 60 minutes
every single day on your business on
achieving the ultimate goal to allow the
momentum to build up most of you aren't
hitting that because you're not
consistent enough number six is your
environment sucks a touch-tones a little
bit earlier but the environment you're
in matters you are likely to be like
your parents you're likely to be like
your friend likely to be like the people
around you it's really hard to break
through how do you break through you
start changing those things and you may
say well I don't I don't know how to
hang out with different people I don't
know how to get access to them if you're
face to face person and go start to meet
them go to events go to conferences go
to meetups go to the places where the
people who you want to be like people
who you want to associate with are
hanging out because they may not be in
your backyard I may not be on the
streets where you grew up for me it came
from books initially and it now comes
from videos I feel like I'm hanging
around Steve Jobs and Oprah Winfrey and
the people that I profile on my channel
I feel like every time I watch their
videos a little piece of them their
thinking their mindset their their way
of being seeps into me
not to help me become like them but to
help to me become a better version of me
to help me play a bigger game to help me
have more confidence to help me believe
more so those are the people that I hang
out with on a consistent basis because
it to be honest a lot of my friends
they're not pushing me just happens with
a lot of entrepreneurs your friends
don't push you your friends respect you
your friends might be jealous of you
your friends might
saying what you're doing is really
stupid or they may be saying I wish I
could do what you're doing
but who's telling you you're doing a
good job and you should be doing more
like you should be playing way out here
and you're you're playing this small
game a lot of us don't have that because
you don't have a boss that's what a good
boss does what a good mentor does is
they see the untapped potential in you
and help you get to where you should be
as opposed to where you're limiting
yourself we don't have that a lot of
entrepreneurs we are our own boss and
yet sometimes our clients will push us
and we'll have to make deadlines and
those kinds of things but in general you
know you could be working harder you
know you haven't reached your ceiling
and you're not pushing yourself through
the discomfort to go and reach that
potential and there's nobody else there
doing it for you and so creating the
environment that forces you to go out
and do it whether it's finding mentors
whether it's finding new friends whether
it's watching videos whether it's losing
the podcasts whether it's consuming
books whatever it is look at look at the
things that are around you your
environment what's what's on the wall in
front of you all of those things matter
you want to create an environment and a
morning routine especially rituals they
get you set up to do something amazing
today we've all felt those moments of
boldness where you felt unstoppable
where things would be amazing for you
and then the rest of the week kind of
sucked so whenever you felt whatever was
happening they got you all jazzed up and
excited what are you watching interview
or whatever it was do that first thing
every day in the morning and you'll need
to find different sources is all your
doing listen to the same video every day
you're going to get bored of it it may
last for a week and then it's going to
lose its effect but another video can
help you and another video can help you
in another video could help you which is
why start at the end stressful series is
the morning daily thing to give you a
shot of ideas and inspiration and wisdom
and energy to do something powerful and
amazing in your business in your life
today whether you're watching special
series or not it doesn't matter to me
but find something that makes you feel
bold inspired and energetic and do that
first thing in the morning every single
day to set yourself up for success and
the number seven reason why you have not
achieved your ultimate goal is just a
lack of self-awareness as I've been
going through this process of helping
people find their one word I found how
little people actually know about
themselves
how often people have sat in the
industry just because that was the
practical thing to do
I said their parents wanted them to do
that's what they started University so
they just kept along that path and
people have very little self-awareness
for who they actually are what do they
value if you don't know what you stand
for then you're just going to be subject
to what other people stand for everybody
has a plan for you your parents your
friends your colleagues your customers
your suppliers your investors everybody
has a plan for you of what you should be
doing with your life that serves them if
you don't have a great plan for yourself
you're just going to be following
everybody else's plan you're never going
to get anywhere amazing and so whether
you believe in finding the one word and
applying that to your life in your
business or you go some other path the
idea of self-awareness is really
important why I find it so helpful is
because I've realized that everything in
my life has led up to where I am right
now and believe has always played a part
in it believe is my one word it's always
played a part of it my favorite songs
about believe my favorite movie is
Seabiscuit which is about believe my
parents taught me believe everything has
been good in my life came through the
lens of believe but it happened
at random these random moments of
greatness happened to me when you
understand what your one word is when
you have the self-awareness then now you
could take that and start planning so
that these good things happen to you on
purpose going forward that you recognize
them that you start hanging around the
right people that you start making the
powerful clear decisions that you start
getting a result you start achieving
your goals otherwise you're going to
continue to live a random path and you
can continue to live up to other
people's expectations of what they want
for you instead of the life that you
want from yourself and so whether you're
going with one word you have another
tool to help you having a self-awareness
to understand who you are what you're
staying for why you're here what the
powerful thing is that you want to do
makes a huge difference for your clarity
your focus and for your ability to
follow through and actually achieving
that ultimate goal for yourself so those
are my suggestions on the seven reasons
why you have not yet achieved your
ultimate goal I'd love to know what do
you guys think always your favorite rule
and why did I miss an eight nine-ten
that you want to add to the list let me
know down in the comments to be curious
if you grab what you guys have to say
I also want to give a quick shout out to
Helena of throw sky from Helena
Ostrovsky calm thank you so much and
Lena picking up a copy of my book your
one word it really really really means a
lot to me and I hope you're enjoying the
read thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon